what do you think about Yemen's houti
Rebels attacking Israel in response to
October 7th and then the United States
and the
UK um initiating bombing of multiple
Targets in Yemen in response to that
yeah I think that it's clear that the
United States cares more about its
shipping lanes than it does about
Palestinian lives and that actually has
proved it uh look I do not support the
houthis as
houthis or their policies in general um
but if you look at what has transpired
and what they have said they're
attacking these ships in response to the
occupation uh or in response to the
genocide and saying that they will
continue to do so to stop business as
usual until a ceasefire is reached they
have not killed anyone right they have
SE seed ships they have blocked the
lanes but they have said that if a
ceasefire happens they will cease their
activity so instead of the United States
trying to get a ceasefire through the
United States decided let's go bomb
Yemen too you know let's let's spend
more money on weapons and killing
innocent people which shows you exactly
where our policy uh always leads itself
to unfortunately so uh I think that most
reasonable people would say that the
problem is not with uh yemeni Rebels
attacking ships the problem is with
Israel attacking innocent Palestinian
lives you mentioned paying respects to
the uh Legacy of ebj Eddie Bernice
Johnson and um remembering Palestinian
child prisoners can you
explain so congresswoman Eddie Bernice
Johnson was one of the few co-sponsors
of a bill that has been on the floor of
Cong Congress for years uh initially
sponsored by congresswoman Betty
McCullum to penalize Israel for its
Detention of child prisoners thousands
of children arbitrarily detained put in
military courts solitary confinement and
yes sexual violence that's been
documented by human rights organizations
against them and there have been no
repercussions so I want you to think
about this you know just the thought of
condition